extreme heats and Bush lives are a
staple of every Australian summer but
new record temperatures and the length
of time the fires have been burning have
turned this into a crisis more than
2,000 firefighters have been struggling
to deal with 100 blazes half of which
are out of control some of those
volunteer firefighters have seen their
own homes destroyed I've been speaking
to our team down there and and
absolutely they're shattered but there's
they know there's a job to do and
they're continuing to get out there and
try and save and protect as many in as
as much of the other infrastructure and
and valuable assets throughout their
local community so naturally they and
their families and their colleagues are
truly devastated by the loss the
national record high temperature has
been broken two days running the new
record of 41 point nine Celsius a full
one degree higher than it was the day
before
nullabor in the south of the country saw
the mercury rise to forty nine point
nine Celsius
here are some other mind-boggling
figures Sydney normally a byword for
blue sea and even bluer sky has been
shrouded in hazardous air pollution for
28 days since the start of November when
a pollution exposure is short it's easy
to tell people gives people advice about
how to avoid it stay indoors
avoid physical activity but when it's
sustained over a number of days or weeks
then the messaging becomes more
complicated and the evidence is not as
strong as to what we actually do about
it especially for a population it's
because as big as Sydney there's been a
huge increase in the number of people
seeking medical treatment and Fanning
the flames of public anger is the Prime
Minister's decision to leave the country
on holiday officials won't confirm where
Scott Morrison has taken his family but
it's reported to be Hawaii we want to be
listened to we want a future he's played
down climate change as the overriding
factor in the spate of bush fires heat
waves are becoming longer and more
severe
our bushfire season is creeping into
spring and winter we are living in a
dangerous climate and it is time for our
prime minister to get out of pockets of
the coal and gas lobby groups and to
start thinking about the future of
Australians sport is impacted to heat
stopped play and a match the New Zealand
cricket team were due to play in
Melbourne with 45 degree heat forecast
this was a warm-up match they've decided
to put on ice in woods Sky News